débat de l'entre-deux-tours qualifié de
rater départ de florian philippot et la
sphère des assistants eurodéputés le
front national est en pleine tourmente
depuis les élections présidentielles de
mai dernier
son maître mot aujourd'hui
reconstruction nos adhérents sont en
attente en attente de notre fondation
ils veulent savoir ce que ça va
comporter exactement quelle est notre
avenir à court terme à moyen terme et
j'espère avoir pu leur apporter un
certain nombre de réponses à ça car oui
nous sommes en pleine refondation aux
fondations qui a été souhaité par marine
et qu'elle met en oeuvre progressivement
jusqu'au congrès en mars
une reconquête des militants s'opère à
présent à l'échelle nationale mais aussi
et surtout auprès des départements et
des municipalités
l'objectif regagner une unité je pense
qu'il faut absolument mettre en valeur
nos équipes municipales en cercle à
l'immense chance d'avoir un maire front
national avec maintenant que la ville
est par ailleurs des équipes aussi dans
l'opposition qui sont qui veille qui
veille à la démocratie à la bonne
gestion de local est une équipe forte
comme celles des mureaux qu'on entend
pas souvent donné la parole aux
militants pour mieux les connaître c'est
le souhait également du parti le 14
novembre dernier un questionnaire a été
lancé auprès des adhérents
on est vraiment dans la refondation
c'est des ronces et qu'on est dans une
période sans élection proche donc de
restructuration des coûte surtout les
électeurs des militants de c'est de
savoir ce qui a déçu ce qu'ils attendent
les nombreux départs au sein du fn dans
les yvelines françois simeoni anciens
présidents yvelinois du fn puis yasmine
belmadi ancien conseiller régional
fragilise le parti
la récente élection de laurent wauquiez
à la présidence des républicains ne
semblent pas quant à elle les inquiéter